you're great
good to see you now Sly I want to start
with you a few months ago we had an
opportunity to chat here in Toronto when
I interviewed you and asked you about
this show you said you were having fun
filming it but that you felt embarrassed
daily like on the daily doing the show
did that change over the course of
filming how do you feel about it now I
feel actually it was a learning
experience I know that term is used
ad nauseum but it was I learned to
really relax and enjoy it and realize
this is a whole different art form you
know I mean because it is it's not easy
to do it's like people used to just miss
action films like oh that's easy I go no
it's really hard to do well reality show
is also really hard to do and now I've
embraced and I love it I love my
daughter my wife so we're having a good
time and people are really seeing
something as actually being documented
it's not being set up
now I imagine when you're in a scenario
with cameras on there are certain
instincts that kick into gear Jennifer
did you notice when the cameras were
around that he got into sort of like any
kind of mode any sort of professional
mode would you like
I think a couple times he did like we're
just like oh my God the camera's still
rolling so you got to stop or you're
wearing a mic you can't like talk about
that kind of stuff
um but most of the time you know just
all of us have been in this world for so
long the girls grew up on a movie set so
we're kind of used to this and and in a
way it just it felt kind of like home I
mean we were so used to each other we
can finish each other's sentences so it
it wasn't as nerve-wracking I think if
we were never in the this business right
it would have been a lot harder but
because we've always had cameras in our
lives at some well not not much with us
though well not much but you've been on
a set of movies no yeah like we grew up
watching it and stuff but it was kind of
it was kind of nerve-wracking for me
especially too because I I was not
really in the spotlight at all neither
and you're a full-time college student
um yeah they they have their podcast
going on like a full-time I'm going to
college right now so it
it was hard for me to open up in front
of this camera
well I think everyone looks great on the
show Sophia you know I think when people
saw your podcast Sistine and Sophia with
your dad on it together it kind of
opened people's eyes to be like oh this
is a really cool Dynamic that they've
got that's actually what started this
whole idea is because we've been doing
this podcast and we had my dad and we've
had our mom on twice and we got so many
responses from people saying like show
more do more and my dad had his little
Instagram stories my mom would share
photos and we would share behind this
what was really fascinating about when
we released that podcast was everyone's
astonishment to how funny he was how
smart my mom is I mean really people
didn't know us on a personal deep level
so that's why this reality show is going
to be so much fun and we think people
are really going to enjoy it because
it's a totally different side that no
one has seen completely oh yeah
I think it's those details that people
are going to latch on to like Sly you're
a big fan of the bachelor oh yeah he's a
bachelor Dancing with the Stars below
deck below 90 days
come on my gypsy weddings nobody gypsy
wedding yeah he likes them also
RuPaul's Drag Race
Dr pimple popper come on
yeah that one I peeked with
not just not just everybody can say you
know that they've been in the meat
locker punching a cow carcass but
they've sat down and they've watched The
Bachelor so this is what it's all about
right yeah it's so relatable There's
Hope for everyone that's all I can say
I love that
um uh Sly you're like a real girl dad
but you you did this thing where you
went I got them to learn how I do things
like they've got to have a routine they
got to be tough but Jennifer when you've
been watching him as a parent like
what's the most like girl dad girly girl
dad you've you've seen him be well he
loves to do their hair and stop it's
true it is true so when they were little
he always would cut their hair blow dry
it not unbelievable word of this my my
niece's hair they radar braid it color
it do everything diet by the way I'll be
honest it was I went to beautician
school when I was 16 for about three
weeks and I realized people are walking
out of their balls it was I just had no
talent look at these hands what really
but you thought you could experiment on
the ground but I could experiment on
them because they can't complain that's
it that's true
around oh it was horrible it was
horrible we had Roots we
mark up here
uh there's a great line you know you're
talking to Sophia
um in one of the episodes and you talk
about time being currency and this is
kind of a theme here with this show
being the fact that you know it's like
being away so much with your work yeah
being so busy right yeah if you could go
back is is there anything about
with that in mind time being currency
that you would do differently or would
you just like everything everything
memories with your family not not
everyone goes I wouldn't change a thing
oh BS give me a break wouldn't change
the thing oh no yeah you would and
especially the amount of time the active
kind of films I chose the locations and
what you sacrifice for that I mean you
come back you're gone so long you almost
have to wear a name tag hi I'm dad you
know that kind of thing so I would never
go through with that again never never
never never and I feel as though those
are precious moments gone forever and I
feel really bad and you also lose how to
interact you know there's a certain
Dynamic that's very delicate in a family
and if you're not part of it you come in
you're kind of like a stranger you don't
get with that flow for a long time then
when you do good with the flow guess
what Call of the Wild time to move off
well where are we going oh the
Philippines see you later six months
that kind of thing Bulgaria and yeah I
change it all
I would just do reality TV I just stay
home